IAN LEWIS: Hi there.
Alright.
Well's let's go ahead
and get started.
Welcome to Programming the
Web With Native Code.
I'm Ian Lewis.
This is David Springer.
Just to give you an idea
of our backgrounds.
I spent several years
working at Microsoft.
Dave spent several years
working at Apple.
And we're coming together
at Google to make the
world a better place.
DAVID SPRINGER: We're
all just getting along.
IAN LEWIS: Before we begin, we
want to remind you that you
can follow along on Wave.
If you'd like to be sitting
there typing instead of
listening, that's fine.
This URL is what
you need to go to.
So what are we going
to talk about today?
Well first we are going to
start with an overview of
Native Client-- what it
is and why is it cool.
Then we're going to talk about
our new Native Client SDK,
which make it easier to develop
applications for Native Client.
And to show you how to
use the SDK, Dave's put
together a tutorial.
He'll build a simple app using
Native Client, and JavaScript,
and web technologies.
And then finally we're going to
show you a little bit about
what's in the pipeline for
the Native Client team.
Now there's a few things we're
not going to talk about today.
We're not going to talk about
the nitty-gritty internals of
our security model or
our runtime system.
We talked about that last year.
And to be honest, it hasn't
really changed all that much.
What's new this year is that we
now have an implementation the
you can actually use to write
real world applications.
So this year what we'd like
to do is focus a little bit
more on the developer story.
Although if you do have
questions about our security
model, or you want to shoot
holes in it, we'd love you to.
And we'll give you some
URLs to go to at the end
of the presentation.
And before we get too far into
this there's one thing we do
need to get out of the way.
We're developers.
And developers like
short identifiers.
So even though the project name
is Native Client, we're going
to shorten that to NaCl.
We pronounce it nackel.
It's a source of all sorts of
sodium chloride related puns.
When you hear us say
nackle, that's what
we're talking about.
So what is NaCl?
And why should you care?
Well NaCl is two things.
First it's a portable system
for verifying and executing
untrusted code-- native
code-- inside the browser.
There are some terms there that
can be a little bit confusing.
So let's define those
before we go any further.
When we say native code, we're
talking about the actual
machine language of the CPU
that your client is running.
That is raw machine code bites.
Untrusted is a word that
has specific meaning
to security geeks.
To layman I think it sounds
a little bit scary.
But in this context what it
means is code that you don't
have to trust, because you
haven't given it
any privileges.
Of course when you put together
untrusted and native code,
things can get a little scary
because there's all sorts of
tricks that you can use in
native code to get privileges
even though you haven't
been given them, right?
So that's where
verification comes in.
When we say verify, what we
mean is we dissemble the code
and run it through a special
algorithm that's going to prove
whether or not the code has the
ability to exit its sandbox.
And if it has any possibility
of exiting the sandbox,
we don't run it.
That's our security model.
And to understand why this is
interesting, think about the
two ways that are most popular
for running code in
the browser today.
You can write code in
JavaScript which is portable.
And it's safe.
And it's awesome.
And you're going to hear a lot
about it at this conference.
But you do give up a little
performance when you do that.
Well if you want that
performance you can write in a
compiled language like C or C
.
You generate you know, an MPI
plugin, or an ActiveX plugin.
That'll give you
your performance.
But say goodbye to
safety and portability.
The goal of Native Client
is to give you both.
The safety of JavaScript
with the performance of C
.
And we feel like we've
gotten pretty close.
Native Client is also
a runtime sandbox.
So I like to think of this
as a sort of mini OS
inside your browser.
And it's got all the things
that a normal OS has, except
they're all webified.
So it's got a POSIX API.
It's got a kernel, what
it basically Chrome.
It's got a Windows
manager which is HTML5.
And it's got a
multimedia layer.
And that's something called
Pepper that we're going to
talk about in a few minutes.
Because we're running in this
virtual mini OS, the code that
you write in NaCl is 100%
portable across Mac and
Windows and Linux.
You don't have to rewrite it.
You don't have to recompile
it in most cases.
What do you do with
something like this?
Well so you've got a desktop
application and you want
to import it to the web.
If you recompile your code for
inside Native Client, you lose
the install and you get all the
performance that you're used
to getting on the desktop.
Or maybe you've got a web app
already, and you just want
to turbo charge it a bit.
This actually happened to a
team we've got in Boulder
that's making sort of a
sketch-up for the web
type of application.
And they wanted to use this
gargantuan, computational
geometry library called CGAL.
It's a huge, huge library.
It's taken man, you know,
huge centuries to write.
There's no way you're going
to port that to JavaScript.
There's no way that you're
going to get equivalent
functionality in JavaScript.
But by recompiling it for
Native Client, we're able to
hook to that from JavaScript
and keep the same performance
and functionality
that we had in C.
So if you've got functionality
that's been compiled in C
already, you can use that
in your web applications.
And another way that you might
use Native Client is if you've
already got a plugin, but you'd
like to move from the sort of
unsafe, insecure model
of Raw, C and C
, ActiveX, NPAPI and what
have you, into a more
safe sandbox model.
The Native Client allows you to
just recompile that plugin, run
it inside of our sandbox, and
you get all of the safety of
Native Client without having
to give up the power
of Native plugins.
So at this point you're
probably thinking
wow, that's great.
What's the catch, right?
There are some pain points.
The first pain point is that in
order for us to verify the
code, you need to compile
code that is verifiable.
That's not too difficult.
What it means is it has
to follow a certain set
of rules that make it
reliably disassemble-able.
We need to be able to reliably
disassemble your code.
That means that it's going
to be slightly larger.
And in many cases run
slightly slower.
But the performance
difference is very minor.
Another thing that is less than
optimal is that you don't get
all of your UNIX sys calls.
But on the other hand, they're
sort of the same sys calls that
you wouldn't expect to get in a
sandboxed environment anyway.
So you don't get to play
with the user's file
system directly.
You don't get to create sockets
or processes willy-nilly.
But you can create threads.
You can create web sockets.
And you can talk to your server
the same way JavaScript can.
Finally, although we've been
putting a lot of work into
our STK, there are still a
bunch of rough edges that
we're polishing off.
I wouldn't expect it to run
perfectly right out of a box
for every case right now.
But as Dave will show you, it's
actually quite easy to use.
And we're working on
making it easier.
So to recap, how does Native
Client make your life better?
Well first it gives you
the performance of
native compiled code.
It gives you a platform
independent multimedia layer.
It gives you the ability
to write in your
choice of language.
Because we look at machine
code, not interpreted
code like JavaScript.
It gives you the ability to do
things like create threads
and talk to web sockets.
And finally, best of all from
my point of view, you're never
going to see this dialog again.
This is sort of my artist
impression of the dialog you'd
see on let's say a certain
operating system, if you're
going to install let's
say an NPAPI plugin.
I've always felt-- I don't know
how you feel-- but I've always
felt like this dialog is making
me make an impossible
choice, right?
I might trust your company.
At least I might trust your
company not to be evil.
But I don't trust you
not to make a mistake.
I don't trust you to not
have a bug that turns into
a huge security flaw.
So how can I really say yes
or no to this client, right?
Native Client is the end
of the, do you trust
this publisher dialog.
And that's probably the
coolest thing about it.
So just to give you an example
of the kind of applications
that you can write
in Native Client.
You probably saw this if
you went to the keynote.
But the Unity game, Lego Star
Wars, this was a project that
we got the opportunity to
port about five weeks ago.
It was about four weeks
of effort by a team
of about four guys.
Not only porting the game and
the runtime engine, but also
the Mono compiler and runtime.
They're doing all of that--
porting it to Native Client
with four guys in four weeks.
So you can see that this
isn't a really super
difficult thing to do.
So let's look at why this is
getting easier all the time,
the Native Client SDK.
If you download the Native
Client SDK, you're going to
find a tool chain that looks
very familiar if you've worked
with Linux or Mac or Cygwin.
It's a standard new tool
chain, has all the libraries
you'd expect, and it has
something called Pepper.
A Pepper is a platform
independent multimedia API
and implementation of NPAPI.
What this means is if you've
ever written an NPAPI plugin,
you know you've always got to
do a little bit of fiddling and
some ifdefs here and there
to sort of paper over the
differences between platforms.
Pepper gets rid of those
differences and adds audio,
video, and OpenGLES and the
ability to talk directly
to JavaScript.
So you can be writing C, or C
, or Python or Ruby, or Go, or
any language that you want,
as long as it has a
compiler for NaCl.
And you can talk to the
JavaScript, the HTML DOM, and
the audio, and video, and
OpenGL that we provide through
Pepper in your Native
Client executable.
And there's also some sample
code, and some scripts, and
some things that will hopefully
make your life a little easier.
As I mentioned, if you want to
use the SDK, if you've used new
toolchain before, things will
look very familiar to you.
You should be able to get off
the ground very quickly.
One little quirk is that you do
need to run in a web browser.
Which means that you need
to have a web server.
So we actually bundle
one of those with the
Native Client SDK.
We've got a little Python
HTTPD that you can run.
And our debugging story quite
honestly is not fully baked.
But at this point you
can debug with GDB.
And we'll talk a little bit
later about our upcoming plans
for more debugging support.
Alright so now we've talked
about what NaCl is, and a
little bit about how
we've tried to make
it easier to program.
Now David Springer is going to
show you how you can use the
NaCl SDK to turbo charge a
web app with Native Client.
DAVID SPRINGER: Thanks Ian.
My plan is to write a little
application in front of
you so this demo can be
really, really short.
Because all this
stuff is really new.
So hang on to your
pocket protectors.
Here we go.
Let me talk about a NaCl
web application a little
bit first-- how this
thing gets set up.
A lot of you probably know
about the Model-View-Controller
design pattern.
This is very similar.
You really are building
a web application.
And we're going to
add this kind of C
back end to it.
So this is the web application
we're going to attempt to
build here, is this
little calculator.
This is obviously
very contrived.
You wouldn't normally just
do a calculator with C
00:14:12,98 --> 00:14:12,54
code.
But the idea is to kind
of show you how this
all works together.
So under the hood of this
there are these basic parts.
The first one is of
course the JavaScript.
So that's where all your
user interface and a lot
of that kind of model and
controller logic sits.
And in your markup,
and your CSS, etc.
And in our world, in the Native
Client web app world, that
talks through an interop
bridge which we call Pepper.
So back to the bad puns,
we have salt and pepper.
Anyway so that's the
interop bridge.
And that's the stuff that glues
the JavaScript to the C
.
And that then speaks through
this sandbox layer that
Ian talked about earlier.
So we don't want your C
code getting out of this
sandbox to our validaters
and stuff like that.
You're not to do that.
And then your actual C
module, which we call
nexe, Native Client
executables of course.
They sit inside that sandbox.
So let's do this.
First thing you have to do if
you're going to write a web
app with Native Client is
get an SDK and install it.
That's a normal step
and everything.
But there is an
SDK that you get.
There's URLs at the end of the
talk of where to go to get
all that kind of stuff.
I'm going to organize this
tutorial in three parts, which
kind of reflect the three basic
pieces of the architecture.
There is the application
which is all done in
HTML, CSS and JavaScript.
So it's primarily a web app.
That's what we're writing here.
And if you were in the talk
previous to this one, which is
the Chrome developer tools, you
saw that we have all these
amazing developer tools to help
you build web apps, debug the
JavaScript, and so
on and so forth.
You can use all those
properties to build the
application section
of your web app.
The second piece is the NaCl
module itself, which is the C
.
And that's where I'm going to
build all the meat of the
computation engine,
if you will.
And this computation in this
example is really, really tiny.
But you can imagine
larger ones.
And then the third piece is
this experimental object layer
that we're building which
handles all the interop.
And we're calling it sea salt,
just to continue the bad puns.
The idea of sea salt is that it
simplifies the interop between
the JavaScript and your C
code.
So that's kind of what
we're actively working on.
I lead a team out in
Boulder-- beautiful Boulder,
Colorado-- that is building
this SDK right now.
OK, let's start
with the UI stuff.
So now we're going to actually
program the application.
This is HTML and CSS.
It's absolutely stuff
you've all seen.
There's nothing really magical
about it, except for the
magical parts of HTML.
So you know, we've got a
div with the calculator.
We've got this little form
that's going to show the
result, and buttons.
And this is the CSS behind
the button, nothing
amazingly special there.
And what I'm going to do
also, in this part of
the application, is add
some functional stuff.
So when you click the
equals button it'll call
this start calculate.
So I just wire up start
calculate to the on-click.
And here's the JavaScript
now to do that.
So again all very
straightforward web application
programming, right?
A couple things to point out in
this function are that the
calculated way that I've kinda
architected this-- if you can
call it that-- is that you type
in an infix notation
expression.
And then I'm going to
turn it into a postfix.
And then feed that into a
calculator object to produce a
result to evaluate the postfix.
Well the infix to postfix
conversion is actually a lot of
string processing which is way
easier for me to do in
JavaScript then in C
.
So I actually just coded
all that in JavaScript.
The point being that when
you're writing these web apps,
write in the language and the
environment that makes
most sense to you.
If it makes a lot of sense
to you to do this kind
of conversion in C
, then it's fine to
do it there too.
This is just how I happened
to do it because it
was easier for me.
Another thing to point out is
that the nexe module, that
we're going to build in the
next stage of this, just looks
like a JavaScript object.
According to the JavaScript,
it's just another object.
There's nothing special about
it, or anything really
special that you have to do.
And you can see here
that it's an object.
And it has this
calculate method.
The calculate method on that
object gets two parameters.
It gets the postfix expression
as an array of course.
And it also takes
a closure object.
So the idea is that the
calculator figures out the
answer and then calls the
closure with the result.
And then there's that binding.
So again, very straightforward
JavaScript stuff.
If you're familiar with
JavaScript, this is going
to be nothing new to you.
OK, so let's take a look
at what that looks like.
I have everything live here
so hopefully this works.
So first thing I want to
do is point out that this
is a web app, right?
So I have to start this
little local server.
And I'm going to do
that right now.
So here we go with out
little local server.
And that comes with the SDK.
If you have your own web server
that you normally publish to,
you can put your nexes there.
This is just something that
makes my life a little easier.
So the other thing I want to
point out is that I am using
the idea I am most
comfortable with.
I happen to write a lot of
stuff in Xcode because I worked
at Apple for a long time.
So I built this whole
application inside of
Xcode which you can do.
I hooked this all up so
that I should be able to
just say build and run.
And it will of hopefully launch
Chrome with the calculator.
So there it is.
Again so I don't
have any nexe yet.
So this is all just
HTML, CSS, JavaScript.
It's a pure web app at
this point with no Native
Client module yet.
And here's what it does:
we can click buttons.
Hopefully you can see that.
So I can say 8 plus 3.
And it's doing things.
And then when I hit equals,
of course, there is no nexe.
So I wrapped all that inside
of a try/catch block.
And because the calculator
object doesn't exist, it hits
the catch clause which just
says the answer must be
42 because that's the
answer to everything.
OK, so that was step one.
Moving on the step two, let's
build up the nexe now.
So now I'm going to add some C
code and actually make this
do a little bit more.
Here is some C
code.
To those of you who
have written C
, this should look
fairly familiar.
And what we do with this sea
salt-- again this is the
experimental object layer--
is that we say OK you're
building a module.
So in C
we create this module.
And part of that initialization
process is the sea salt layer
asks you, what methods
does your module have?
So it calls this initialized
method on your object.
And what we're going to do is
bind it to the calculate C
method.
So the idea is that we have
this calculated method in
JavaScript that is going to
eventually flow into this
calculate method in C
.
And how that works is that we
make a little binder thing and
then say add method
name calculate.
And then that goes out
into the JavaScript.
And this is what it looks
like in JavaScript.
So no surprises.
So the JavaScript calculate and
the sea salt bridging layer
works through Pepper and
through the sandbox and all
that stuff, to make this
JavaScript call eventually
go into the C
.
OK, so back in the C
now, we'll continue
with what happens.
We're going to write
little Pepper stuff.
So now I'm filling out the
actual calculate method.
And you can see here the first
thing I do is grab that array.
So the expression array is
create array from NP variant.
That's just Pepper stuff.
And like I say, the sea salt
thing is very experimental.
We're still working out
all the details fo this.
But then what I do is I say,
all right, call evaluate
expression which is my C
it's the guts of my C
stuff, and give me
a double result.
And here's what the evaluated
expression looks like.
It's a really, really
simple postfix.
It doesn't even work that well.
But it's a demo.
And then it produces a result.
Now we're going to write a
little bit more Pepper stuff to
push that result back over the
bridge and call that
closure object.
So that's what this, in right
below that if statement, all
that if clause, is you can see
it's pulling out the result,
turning it into a thing that's
digestible by JavaScript.
And then it just says this en
vogue default, which is the
wait from within your nexe to
call back out to the
JavaScript function.
And now back into the
JavaScript, here's
what that looks like.
This closure will get called
with the double result.
OK, so let's see what
that looks like.
We had such good luck
with the first run.
Just let me go to calculator
two-- again Xcode project.
One thing I do want to point
out here is that what I did
was, in Xcode you can glue
a custom executable to it,
which I just made chromium.
But one of the things-- and
this is explained in the SDK
documents-- is that you have to
add this dash, dash, enable
NaCl flag when you're going
to do Native Client modules.
Because we are still kind
of experimental, we
are behind a flag.
Last year we were kind
of a research project.
This year we are becoming
a real project.
So this is getting the full
force of Google behind it.
So I should be able to
build and run this.
Now we have basically
the same thing.
It's going to look the same as
what you just saw because the
whole basic, the whole web app
was already written
in the markup.
And one of the first things
that you notice is different,
is that it says, oh I loaded
the calculator module.
Because the nexe
actually exists now.
So is says, oh you
know I found it.
And I just have a little alert
in there that let's me know
that and let's me know that
my demo's actually working.
So if I say, you know,
7 plus 6 equals 13.
So now it's actually doing the
computations through the C
.
So that's all now
glued together.
OK.
Thank you.
OK one more step.
Let's do more with Pepper and
the kind of the fun stuff
you can do in the C
code.
So we go back to C
again and we will add sound.
So step one of adding sound
is I'm going to expose
this click method.
So again as I explained
before, where you can
say OK, add methods.
Sea salt says, what
are your methods?
I'm going to expose
one called click.
And wire it up to
calculator click.
And then I'm also going
to expose a property
on the object too.
So you know in JavaScript you
can have the functions which
are really just also properties
and scalar properties.
So here sea salt is saying
what are your properties?
And I say OK, I'm going to
make an accessor for my
property and a mutator.
Because I can get
it and set it.
And then I'm going to add this
property named button sound
wired up to the accessor
and mutator there.
So over in the JavaScript
here's what that looks like.
There's the click
method getting called.
So we already went through
that with the calculate.
And here's setting that
property button sound.
It just looks like JavaScript.
There's nothing
special about it.
It should be all very familiar.
OK.
So back into the C
code now.
There's a little bit more work
that we have to do which is
some kind of Pepper stuff.
And that is to actually
implement the accessor
and the mutator.
So here's the accessor,
get button sounds.
And you see all it's doing is
it's just taking an internal
variable inside my object--
that play button sound-- and
sticking it into a variable
that can be digested
by JavaScript.
And here's the mutator.
So I'm grabbing that variable
and using sea salt to do all
the variable marshaling.
Because as you know,
JavaScript variables can
be just about anything.
There's no strong typing,
which is kind of a really
difficult thing for C
programs to get their
head around sometimes.
But the idea is that we get
this thing from JavaScript.
And sea salt says OK, I'm going
to figure out what it is
and then return the most
appropriate boolean value.
If it already is a boolean,
it's just what you get.
But if it's a string, or if
it's a double, or an int, or
whatever else, do some attempts
to make a boolean value
out of that and set it.
So that's what this is doing.
So now let's add
the actual audio.
So that was the set up for it.
And here's the part where we're
going to really set the audio.
When your module actually gets
loaded and then all the devices
are ready for use-- so there's
2-D devices, 3-D devices, these
are all in the SDK examples,
and there's audio-- you
get this call, this
said window call.
It says OK, now you're
live in the browser.
The devices are ready.
You can go to town.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say, all right, I want
to create an audio device.
So I just simply ask Pepper.
I say I want a Pepper
audio device.
And then I configure it.
You just use a whole bunch of
stuff in there to configure
the sound sample type
and everything else.
And then I have this callback
that I give it which we'll
look at a little bit later.
And what's happening is that
a thread gets started in
your Native Client module
that plays the sound.
And that thread continuously
calls this callback saying, I
want more samples for
the buffer to play.
Then I just simply say,
initialize the context.
And I'm ready to go.
So now I have an audio
context in there.
So here's what that audio
callback looks like.
It's really just a very, very
thin wrapper on top of the
synthesize button-click
method inside my object.
So here is the synthesize
button-click method in the
object-- very, very simple.
All it's doing is copying
samples from the button click
sample into the play buffers.
I have a little click pending
piece of state in there to
tell me whether the click
has finished playing or not.
Because Pepper's upward buffers
can be smaller then the wave
sample that I originally have.
I mean wave samples can be very
large and the Pepper buffers
are generally a K or so.
So that's all that is.
It's really, really
simple stuff.
So let's see what
that looks like.
And back to here.
Let me minimize two.
I have three.
It should just be able
to say build and run.
And so by the way, that build
and run stuff, what it's doing
is it's running all the Native
Client compilers, and producing
validated code, and writing out
a nexe for me which I then
load in via my page.
OK, got it.
So now let's see if
this works, sound.
All right.
OK, that's it.
We did it, back to Ian.
IAN LEWIS: Thanks Dave.
So we're still hard at
work at this stuff.
I wanted to let you know
a little bit about
what we're working on.
The first thing that-- it's
actually my team doing this--
is full support for
debugging, not just GDB, but
also Visual Studio.
So that's been a party and a
half getting that to work.
If you have any question
about that, you can ask me.
We're also doing plugins to
support all the popular,
integrated development
environments.
So you'll be able to develop
an Apple code just as
easily as you develop
any other kind of code.
We're working on this interop
library-- the sea salt library
that Dave showed you.
We'd like to make that much
more easy to use so that it
feels more natural, like you're
just programming in your native
language instead of having to
do a lot of marshaling back and
forth between Pepper
and JavaScript.
And finally, probably the most
exciting thing we're working on
is something called
portable NaCl, which we
pronounce pinnacle.
Now portable NaCl is an
LLVM-based bite code
representation of
your native code.
So what that gives you is the
ability to have a portable
representation that can then
be downloaded and compiled on
the client to match the
client's architecture.
Or you could compile it
on the server to match a
client's architecture.
So that's interesting to us
because at this point, although
NaCl has completely crossed
platform with regards to
operating system, it does still
need to be compiled for 32-bit
Intel, and 64-bit Intel,
and ARM as separate nexes.
And what pinnacle allows us
to do is have one nexe that
is completely portable.
And we think that's what
the web is all about.
If this interests you as much
as it interests us, we'd love
to have your contributions
and your comments.
We'd like to hear about your
problems or your triumphs
with this software.
So you can go to
nativeclient.googlecode.com.
You can get the SDK
at nativeclient-sdk
.googlecode.com.
And if you have anything at
all to say about it, please
visit our Native Client
discuss Google group.
If you'd like to see more
demos, we're going to have a
ton of them at our booth in the
developer sandbox, which is
just right around the corner
underneath the big
chrome balloon.
And Dave and I will be
there all afternoon.
And we'll have people from
the Native Client team there
all day tomorrow as well.
So come see us there.
Now to finish up before we take
questions, we actually have a
special guest, out developer
from the Unity team.
Jonas has been able to sneak
in under the nose of the
fire marshal, I guess.
And he's here to talk a
little bit about the Unity
experience on Native Client.
JONAS ECHTERHOFF: So hello.
My name Jonas Echterhoff.
I'm working for
Unity Technologies.
We're developing the Unity game
engine, which is the technology
driving the Star Wars
game you saw before.
So I want to give you a brief
demo of how Unity works,
what is it about.
And then talk about our
motivation for porting it
to Native Client, and my
experience in getting
the port to work.
Now it seems we have a
little problem with the
display connector here.
I'm just going to pluck out
this one and try if that works.
Yeah it did something here.
There we are, great.
So what you're seeing here is
the Unity editor which people
use to develop content.
So Unity is an engine people
use to develop games
or any other kinds of
interactive 3-D content.
People are using it for other
kinds of fence projects
actually, like architectural
visualization or
scientific stuff.
I'm going to give you brief
overflow of some workflows.
So what you see here
is the scene view.
anybody who's using 3-D
modelling tools should
be familiar was the
look and feel of it.
So you can move around your
scene, which is typically
a level in the game.
You can click on anything.
And then it will show up here
in the hierarchy, which is a
list of objects in the scene.
And you can add it
as properties here
in the inspector.
Some objects may have scripts
attached to it which can be
written in C-SHOP or JavaScript
to define behaviors, which is a
way which would set
up your game play.
So down here you have the game
view which is where you can
actually try out what
you're working on.
So any time you can just
hit the play button.
And you can test
your game in here.
So let me just expand that.
And we don't have audio now
because we're using the
different connector.
But this isn't much
of a game really.
I just picked this scene
because it looks so nice.
But one thing we care a
lot about is when people
develop content like this.
They want very fast iteration
times to try out ideas.
Like with traditional game
engines, people might test
their game then decide they're
not quite happy with the look
of something and then re-export
it in their modelling tool,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
make a new bullet of the game
and start over in testing.
And so, I'll show you
how you do it in Unity.
So say we don't like the
look of the zebra crossing.
We just go to the scene
view, find it here.
There we have it.
So we pick it up here
in the inspector.
Here's our texture.
This is the asset view which
contains all the assets
making the project.
We just open the texture
file up in Photoshop,
do some changes to it.
I think this looks nice
so I just save it.
And at the moment you save it,
the editor detects that the
file has been changed on disk
and automatically
re-imports it.
So now you can see the
texture has changed
the end of the game.
I can resume testing right
where I stopped and
resume playing.
We think this is a very fast
process to develop content.
And it works for any
kind of assets.
You can do the same thing
with your 3-D model and
anything you're using.
So you can always test your
game exactly how it would
look in the editor.
But once you want to try it on
the actually bit platform,
you can make a build here.
So as you'll see, we support
lots of different platforms.
We support the common
game consoles.
We have support for Android,
which is new for us.
So we have a small booth with
the developer sandbox where we
showcase that, in case
you're interested.
We support iPhone, standalone's
for mac and PC and we
have the web player.
The Web Player allows you to
embed Unity content in web
pages for rich interactive
experiences people are using
for having games embedded
in Facebook pages.
So far we implemented this
using a custom plugin.
Well it works pretty
well for us.
And lots of people
are installing it.
We have 30 million installs.
That's actually a very
insignificant percentage of
the internet population.
So what we really like is to be
able to have people run our
content without installing
a plugin first.
That's why we're really
excited about Native Client.
Because Native Client will
allow us to run on Chrome
browsers, Chrome OS.
And hopefully at some point,
other browsers will adapt
it as well without any
hurdles for the users.
So right now it runs on
Mac, Windows, and Linux.
This is very cool for us
actually, because we never
had a Linux plugin.
We're always too afraid of
having various different
distribution and driver issues.
Now we have the problem taken
away from us by Google,
which is nice for us.
I guess they can take the pain.
So we just decided to port to
native client very recently.
I heard about it
first a month ago.
So on very short notice I got
on a plane to Mountain View to
work along Google engineers to
get this running to have a
demo for the conference.
Now let me tell you
how it worked for us.
Now getting our code to compile
in [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
wasn't a big problem.
We were already using POSIX
API, since we were running
on the Mac and other
platforms which used them.
Some things we can't do
which we're normally
doing on the web plugin.
We don't have file access,
which we're using for
permanent storage.
We don't have network sockets.
I believe there are plans to
expose some functionality and
the Pepper APIs to have this.
And the Pepper APIs which we
have to use for all hardware
and browser interactions.
So we had to port all
our code to use that.
Like input was very
straightforward.
Audio wasn't a big problem
since fmod the audio library we
use has the ability to mix down
all the 3-D position of the
audio into samples buffers.
Which we can just than
give to the Pepper APIs
David just showed you.
Graphics was a bit more
difficult for us because it
uses OpenGLES 2.0 which can
do pretty much everything
you'd want to do.
It's normally open GL, but
it only has a subset of
the functions you have.
So you have to implement
some things differently.
Like all the rendering
is done using shaders.
So we had to write some code to
convert like non-shader
rendering code, which was like
using the normal vertex
pipeline, to dynamically
generate shaders for us.
We had to do this because we
want of support all of our
content which has deployed
for other platforms as well.
Luckily some of that work was
already done because we're
targeting OpenGLES on the
Android and other
platforms too.
So for us, by far the most
difficult part, was getting the
Mono runtime to work, which
we're using for scripting.
So people write code in
C-SHOP and JavaScript.
This is where we got
help from Google.
Thanks to Brad, and
Nicholas, and Elijah.
Without them this
wouldn't be possible.
They were working on this.
They got the Mono compilers
to actually output Native
Client [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
machine code from the C-SHOP
code, which is great.
So yeah, I mean overall I'm
very happy with the results.
There were some rough edges.
I would certainly have liked
better debugging tools.
We did a lot of
print of debugging.
I mean, this is a product which
is in very active development.
So this should
become much better.
And I encourage anybody who's
interested to download the
NaCl SDK and just try it out.
Or it that sounds too complex
for you, or if you want the
target other platforms, you
might want to give
Unity a chance.
You can download a free version
from our website, unity3d.com.
So that's it from me.
If you have any questions,
I'll be around for a while.
AUDIENCE: Applause.
IAN LEWIS: OK, Thanks so much.
I think we do have a little
bit of time for questions.
I know that some of you
probably have other a
sessions to get to.
So we won't feel too
bad if you walk out.
But Dave and I, or Jonas
can take questions right
now if there are any.
00:45:15,998 --> 00:45:15,984
Yeah?
AUDEINCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on the Chrome browser,
when will you no longer
need to pass the flag?
IAN LEWIS: Do we have a
definitive response for that?
DAVID SPRINGER: Chrome 6.
IAN LEWIS: So we're shooting
for Chrome 6 on that.
Oh, the question was, when do
we get to turn the flag off.
And the answer is Chrome
6 at this point.
We're trying to synchronize
with Chrome releases.
I don't think that we've
issued any guarantees.
AUDIENCE: The other question
is, it sounds like you did a
lot of work to port Mono over.
Is that work going to
be contributed back
to open source?
Is there going to be any
way to get at that code?
IAN LEWIS: I believe
that's open source.
JONAS ECHTERHOFF:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
IAN LEWIS: The question was if
we're going to port Mono, or if
we're going to contribute
the Mono port back.
The Mono port is just 32-bit.
So we still need to
do the 64-bit port.
But the idea is to go ahead
and get all that done.
Any other questions?
OK, like I said, we'll be at
the developer sandbox all day.
So if you have anything else
you want to say to us or
ask us, please stop by.
Thanks a lot.